[Music]
well well well everybody Mr Wonderful
here in a very special magical place if
you're talking watches with two great
watch friends first of all Paul Boutros
the legendary Auctioneer for very
high-end watches the Phillips auction is
legendary ever since the Paul Newman
watch remember that what was that 17
million dollars 17.8 million in 2017.
estimates for 3 million estimate was in
excess of one million he thinks it's
going for one million goes for 17. that
established him as a rock star in the
watch world and of course Teddy belzar a
good friend who's exploring all kinds of
new entry-level watches all the way to
the Collectibles and so we thought we'd
gather today just days ahead of the
Phillips auctions December 2022 because
there's some very very very very special
watches in this tray they're going to
blow your socks off we're going to start
with one that I really care about okay
and it's going to auction it's the
second time I've done this this is for
charity Brigham's Women's Hospital in
Boston
this is the legendary shark tank steel
white face Daytona worn in season 13 of
Shark Tank
now it's with mixed emotions that I talk
about this watch because I love this
piece this is a rock star watch and it's
the most favored by wardrobe designers
for Shark Tank because it works so well
with the suit I'm wearing and this red
puff and the red band but Paul tell us
about the legend of the Daytona
ah so rolex's Daytona is absolutely a
legend it's one of the most iconic one
of the most desirable watches of all
time introduced in 1963. this is the
latest generation steel Daytona the
reference 116500 Ln the ceramic Daytona
as it's well known the design is
inspired by the big red Daytona made in
the 1970s and the 1980s modernized for
today's tastes 40 millimeter case size
in-house Rolex movement
impossible to get at retail as many many
people know and we're honored to have it
donated by you with the proceeds
benefiting the Women's Hospital we're
we're thrilled to have it Kevin thank
you how hard are these to get just if
you wanted to get a Daytona forget about
the Shark Tank Daytona yeah so part of
the legend of the Daytona is it's uh
just it's so hard to get when Rolex
introduced the first self-winding
Daytona in 1988 the waiting list turned
out to be like seven years it was it
went from the worst seller to the best
seller because everyone was waiting for
a self-winding Daytona I heard the story
that Italian men that were living at
home loved that watch so much that they
scooped up the entire European Supply
that was there's all these stories about
Daytona's Teddy you know this watch as
well absolutely and I would say if you
look at the propelling force that's been
Rolex over the last decade I think a big
reason for that is partially the Daytona
the Daytona was it became a cultural
icon in many ways the Paul Newman sale
was I would say the Pinnacle when we saw
this that was it pushed everything
forward in terms of what we've seen with
the Rolex phenomenon that's happening
right now with retail allocation and
also just depreciation on the secondary
Market that was an important moment in
watch collecting Paul Newman's
association with the Rolex Daytona
really propelled its success not only
the success of Rolex and the Daytona but
the success of watch collecting in
general that's true that's a very good
point I'm very excited about this and of
course I want to support the charity
that it's sending proceeds too but it's
just one of many incredible pieces so
let's go down Teddy you've selected six
other crazy pieces Paul agrees let's go
down the Hit Parade here what's next on
the charts do you want to start with
something because we have some crazy
things here that are maybe some of the
most iconic watches of all time crazy
off the charts in terms of their
availability but you also have things
and I think it's important to show this
at certain other people that maybe don't
have all the money to spend could still
take part in these auctions so you want
to start there and then we can Ascend up
absolutely I'm very happy you picked out
this one Teddy this is the Mad one by
Max booster mbnf we look for watches for
people across all walks of life looking
for the greatest watches regardless of
price point this one has a starting bit
of one thousand dollars our published
estimate is one thousand to two thousand
dollars it's offered with no Reserve so
even a one dollar bid could win it
theoretically
this is a very sought after model when
Max booster introduced it he made about
100 for his closest friends and
supporters you can get it for maybe a
dollar you don't know you never know I
promise you will not go it won't be a
doll no reason Lots could sell for very
low okay but what do they trade for in
the secondary markets now the blue the
first version was was only made for his
closest friends and this is an even more
exclusive version of the first version
made specifically for his brand Partners
this one on the secondary Market if it
wasn't the particular provenance that
this one has is probably 12 to 15 000 on
the secondary market for the blues this
one was actually donated for Time for
Art which is a special charitable
auction we're holding in conjunction
with Swiss Institute it was donated by
Eric Giroux who is the legendary
designer behind most of mbnf's Creations
this was his personal watch donating to
raise funds so something for everybody
in this auction and what's really cool
about this is this is a miyota movement
and they're already taking this very
entry level this isn't a watch under 500
you can find that movement but how
they're able to use the traditional
rotation of the oscillating weight to
make it a unique presentation to make it
part of the cool feature and then you
also have on the outside the indication
of time on the outside of the case it's
very cool to show the creativity yeah I
mean it's extremely well made the that
winding rotor like like a battle ax is
made of titanium and tungsten heavily
weighted tungsten's is a very heavy
metal and it just Dances all day long
spinning and it just is mesmerizing it's
beautiful
all right next on the Hit Parade moving
up the feeding chain on price here
obviously okay you know what let's jump
to cover Lots okay so these are on the
front cover of our catalog starting with
the one at the top of our cover it's a
crash it's a car chase crash it is the
legendary Cartier London crash the
original introduced in 1967. how many
were made Paul we have recent knowledge
that approximately one dozen were made
introduced in 1967 the London crash was
sold in the Karcher London Boutique from
about 1967 until 1989 approximately and
over all of those years only about a
dozen were made this is the sixth to
appear publicly it's Absolutely Fresh to
the market it comes from the family of
the original owner who was a woman who
she bought it in 1970 from Cartier in
London she was a world-class collector
of many things she was also a
philanthropist but her jewelry
collection was a standout her jewelry
collection now resides at the Museum of
Fine Arts in Boston it's so into
intriguing I I would almost wear that
myself I know it's a woman's piece no
it's a man's watch actually she was she
was really ahead of her time it's like a
surrealist Salvador Dali just type of
approach and then you mentioned before
he started shooting the price that she
purchased that for at the time yes yes
so they were they underpriced them these
watches were completely handmade they're
really unique only 12. let me guess it's
going to go for half a million bucks so
our estimate is 400 000 to 800 000 and
um yeah thank you it's one way I should
run this Austin
yes you're right don't feed this ego
please but obviously this is going to be
a sought after piece it's extremely
sought after for me it's one of the most
magical watches of the 20th century
there's nothing like it that's fantastic
that's the importance of an auction
house to actually authenticate the
Providence of these watches yes so that
we take a lot of care in vetting every
watch that comes to us not only for
originality quality condition whether
it's stolen or not you know we have a
staff of specialists around the world
who work together with a board of
advisors making certain that the watches
we sell are and I feel the aura of these
pieces let's go let's step it up a notch
I see an FP Jordan in here yes let's
talk about this piece now I'm a huge
urine collector this is incredibly rare
19.99 I can tell this is a very very
early piece and Paul there's something
interesting with this has a spelling
error yes so exactly this is a very
early Jordan piece it's number 38 made
in 1999 so theoretic it could be the
38th jorn ever made it's pink gold dial
it could be the very first Jordan watch
offered with a pink gold dial we're not
sure of that but because it's so early
and no earlier models are known it's
it's a possibility only six examples
were made with pink dial of this
generation of tourbillon the case back
has very shallow Engravings a
characteristic of the earliest Jordans
and as you mentioned it has a wonderful
human error
there's a letter missing in the
engraving it's supposed to spell out inv
for nvin it in Latin yeah
it's missing the V it says investit FP
screwed up on that one the same thing in
the prototype for the resonance that is
another issue it's complete with its
original box and guarantee
um going to go for crazy price I I think
it's going to do well it's estimated at
300 000 to 600. I predict it'll be at
the higher end of the range the the
Jordan fever right now is unprecedented
it really is it's exploded on the scene
I'm considering it the fourth pillar of
watch collecting now after AP Rolex
Patek
it's just as important yeah he's
extremely well loved his designs really
appeal to people around the world and uh
his vision for for watchmaking and his
dedication to time keeping precision and
accuracy it's it's remarkable
all right let's keep moving here there's
some other extraordinary pieces Teddy
your choice
I want to talk about the George Daniels
okay
George Daniels if you don't know what
this is this is this is probably the
Pinnacle of watchmaking for many many
many collectors and something unique
about Phillips you've become sort of uh
the Nexus for this brand in the
secondary market right yeah so we are
how did that happen we are long time
Advocates of independent watchmakers
um we've we've dedicated chapters in our
auction catalogs uh for years because we
believe in independent watchmaking
they're pushing the state of the art of
watchmaking design and also Aesthetics
in the realm of independent watchmakers
George Daniels is widely considered the
Godfather of the current independent uh
movement one of the greatest watchmakers
of all time especially in the 20th
century Smith owes a lot to him yes and
Roger Smith was his mentee his one and
only Protege basically and uh this watch
is the George Daniels anniversary made
in partnership with with Roger Smith so
it was George Daniel's design and Roger
Smith had some input and made them this
has been likely someone who already owns
some of his watches is going to go for
this it's possible because people are
collecting verticals of this if they can
also to provide contact we're talking
about under 50 watches he ever produced
yeah so in in the handmade world of of
George Daniels in his entire lifetime he
made two wrist watches completely
Handmade by himself and about 25 pocket
watches so less than 30. in total by
himself with the partnership with Roger
Smith The Smith's an assistant on this
piece yes yes so Smith helped create it
and of the anniversary pieces there are
about
47. there's 35 in yellow gold 12 in
Platinum and the rest in white gold
smith has also achieved that kind of
legendary status he's no longer taking
orders for watches he's closed his
orders a book closed his order book yeah
he can only make so many they're they're
really handmade they're the Pinnacle of
watchmaking in general and the the Apex
of British watchmaking today okay I'd
like to pull something out of this trade
which I'd never seen before didn't
believe it existed I thought it could
have been a Frankenstein watch or
somebody that somehow painted it with a
spray can what is this AP doing in blue
yes so this is the latest uh version of
Audemars piguet's ceramic watches
announced I believe in September 2022
this is the first one to appear publicly
they're impossible to get everyone we've
shown it to has said to us I've never
seen one before and we've never seen one
before and I thought I've seen
everything so it's it's entirely made of
blue ceramic finish to ap's very high
standard five different finishing
techniques for the case and the bracelet
to do that with Ceramics is extremely
difficult the way light plays off of all
of these surfaces makes the watch very
vibrant and Lively the blue color is a
chameleon
under different lighting conditions it
looks dark blue under some it's bright
blue it's a perpetual calendar 41
millimeters this is a special order
piece there's only one like it with an
Eiffel Tower on the case back the
consignor is a one of a kind this is a
one of a kind
the rotor has an Eiffel Tower at the
center skeletonized Eiffel Tower
the proceeds of the sale all profit will
be donated to a charity
yeah I think this will be generating a
lot of Buzz because nobody's seen it
before and yet it's a legendary piece I
mean this is so legendary
I I'm going to be interested to see what
happens there all right Teddy your turn
there's one left on the table
protect
chronograph
now you cannot go wrong with this piece
give us the history of this I mean
collectibility value long term yeah is
this specifically signed to a retailer
here in the U.S this is this is El
Supremo stuff so yes so the let me see
one of the most important ones for last
so this is another cover lot featured on
the front cover alongside the Cartier
crash this is a Patek Philippe reference
24.99 perpetual calendar chronograph in
the field of collectible patex like
Rolex has the Daytona which is the most
sought after model the most sought after
collectible Patek is widely believed you
know it is
and it is the 24.99 produced since 1951
until about 1985 and only 349 examples
across four different Series this is a
third series example from 1973. it has
dramatic long downturned curved lugs a
very modern case size of about 38
millimeter diameter perfect for today's
tastes really bold beautiful Dauphine
hands all of the dial printing is raised
hard enamel what you see is not ink it's
actually engraved into the surface of
the dial filled with hard enamel baked
into a high temperature oven to be
absolutely indelible just like a tattoo
so it could survive
hundreds of years even if you clean the
dial that print won't go away this watch
is well preserved the Dial's never been
cleaned the case is extremely sharp and
it's absolutely
special because of its uniqueness it's
the only one in the world signed house
house was an American Retailer of Patek
Philippe they had about 10 boutiques in
the west coast of the United States
there are other house signed Patek
Philippe watches there's no other house
signed reference 24.99 it is in a sense
a one of a kind it's a one of a kind
yeah what's the estimate on it once
again four hundred thousand to eight
hundred thousand dollars that's a wide
range are you concerned about the market
being a little softer in the secondary
market for watches right now
uh you know it depends on the type of
watch we've we've seen a bit of softness
in I guess hyped modern pieces that were
made in large quantities call it what it
is Richard Mills for example they've
come off quite a bit it's you know
certain certain brands that were uh
there was a lot of speculation I think
about future growth yeah um and even I
mean just the sports genre I mean but
you talked about if you look at the
pillar of Patek Philippe I mean this is
what I think of I think of perpetual
calendar chronograph this is the design
format that I think of when I think of
the brand people say Nautilus think of
Aqua not but I go back to the 20th
century the Nautilus is Johnny come
lately in the context of uh Patek
Philippe I think 76 and then you have
yeah I mean this this is this is uh
Timeless in the sense that it will be in
style forever exactly and so in the
field of vintage the prices what we've
seen there is slow and steady Healthy
Growth they've actually beaten the s p
for the last 11 years we haven't seen
hype we haven't seen uh crazy price
increases and so the field of inches is
a little bit a different story I think
there is an asset class for me when I
talk to investors watches have come on
the scene now and people are starting to
appreciate portfolio of of pieces you
enjoy you wear them storage it's a
little costly because you have to Vault
them somewhere but they're doing very
well and they're beating the market the
stock market what we say so we say
watches are you know things that you can
wear and enjoy 24 hours a day indoor and
out and they have enduring value if they
go up it's a wonderful thing if they
don't at least at the end of the day you
have something you love and you can wear
and enjoy and how many things in our
day-to-day lives can we actually take
with us everywhere you know you think
about you getting a car but how many how
many hours are you in a car maybe you're
even your shoes your bed there's nothing
really that you spend more time with on
a day-to-day basis and it says something
about you and starts conversations
that's what I love about it and these
dials are so extraordinarily different
it's wonderful
anyways thank you very much Paul thank
you very much Teddy thank you very much
Kevin I can't wait to see what happens
with my white face you know steel
Daytona the classic Shark Tank season
13.
just love this all right thank you
everybody see you soon